and for jose suarez he's won two games
in a row we just talked about him gooby
in the open what do you expect from him
here tonight just to keep that great
pacey's has been working and have
trusted all his pitches in the report
he's having with max that's him
swing at a miss down goes harrison
strikeout number one for suarez he was
having a good season and we know how
good he is defensively here's the pitch
popped in the air in the right center
field it's hanging up under and making
the catch on that one is marsh the
center fielder two up and two down matt
olson will be the next batter now here's
the o2 pitch on the way and matt it's a
high fly ball right field it's deep
rojas back at the track you look and
olson has hit it out and the athletics
take a one-nothing lead number 36 for
matt olson and it just doesn't matter to
matt olson which side it's coming from
left side right side it ends up on the
other side of the wall pack your bags
madio all aboard next stop pound town
one nothing is two out count us at first
here's pinder
one two pitch pin to rips it toward
right center field that's going to get
down it's going to be played off the
wall cannas digging for third kante's
gonna wave him home here comes the relay
throw to the plate and it is late headed
for third pinner he's safe it's two to
nothing a's matt chapman last night one
for three also had a couple of walks
here's the one two two of it he swings
it's a ground ball fair down the left
field line in the corner and pinder can
walk home and chapman's going to second
that's a double and it's three nothing
a's and back to back doubles and the
athletics third extra base hit in this
first inning james caprilian going to be
taking the mound tonight making his 21st
start of the season emotionally
turbulent last
24 36 hours as we talked about james
caprilian initially thought he was going
to find himself in the bullpen three and
two to march a left-handed hitter on the
way and march it's a fly ball left
center playable for marty it's about 10
feet from the track and he makes the
catch one away that'll bring up david
fletcher
praying hustling over but it's going to
be chapman in front of that angels
dugout and the two one fish to otani and
that's what i'm gonna reach for fly ball
to right playable pinder going back on
the track but midway on the track and he
makes the catch and for caprilian it's a
one two three bottom of the first
got the night off feels a little bit
better and he's back in there a little
flare
and a ball that's off the glove of marsh
harrison's gonna high step into second
which he does each and every time he has
a double
line to right field
rojas makes the catch
and suarez gets out of the ending
three two pitch on the way swing on fly
ball right field pinder about four steps
to his right makes the catch one away
here's the one-two pitch and that's
swung on grounded to the right side in
the shift taking a second harrison fires
to first inside two way
up the middle
chapman's got it with the shift on so i
think
caprilian got a little bit of leather on
that may have helped the situation
doug's happy so are we six up six down
for james caprilian
here's the one two curve ball that
strike three call top of the zone and
stassey thought it was upstairs didn't
like the call
2-2 swing and a miss blew it by him at
94.
[Applause]
a couple lefties there
martay backs up
and he's got it
chapman strikes out and he gets him to
chase a curveball and he struck him out
[Applause]
hits a ground ball jack mayfield stabs
it throws across and gets davis
oh what a stop by renipo
what a play with a scoop
beautiful play
renifo
[Applause]
fletcher
bounces one to chapman chapman's got it
fires across just in time
got him swinging came right at him with
a fastball and ohtani swung through it
right there he just threw it right by
him 94 miles an hour really right down
the middle
there's a line drive up the bat a
harrison right at the angel shortstop
randhifo so he was crouching down to
catch that one it was hit right at him
that's the first down in the inning
strikes out martay two down
ground ball renefa was there to fletcher
6'4 gets out of the ending no damage
so that's swung on a five ball center
field marta back here in the track about
10 feet from the track
and the pitch to renji fo and that's
swung on a five ball playable
right field pinder angling toward right
center it's going to be marta the center
fielder making the catch about 20 feet
left to straight away center
[Applause]
bus drives from the center busy
inning for marte he's got it and
caprilian is rolling along he's allowed
just one hit
so the yankees strike three called
stassi
called out on that high fastball again
dallas
line drive center field marty's on his
horse is he gonna get there over his
head
jack mayfield
gonna stop right there it's a one out
double hit that one
[Applause]
well one is
driven toward left but ken is there he's
got it
[Applause]
big bouncer
harrison to first and
caprilian does the job is they strand
mayfield at second base terrific six
innings for james caprilian so it's in
the hands of the oakland bullpen shohei
ohtani leads things off and bounces one
through on the left side might have
cracked his bat on that one he did and
he just beat the shift right there
and rengifo who's been swinging a hot
bat although for two tonight he'll be
the next batter and now the 2-2
is delivered and it's pulled up first
picked up by osaka's the second for one
elvis back to first with garrett
covering it's in time even though he
dropped the baseball he held on long
enough and out of first base is randhifo
save the first
wow looks like bob melvin's been thrown
out so here's rojas at the play with two
outs
up the middle line drive basically
he scores it's a 3-1 game
strike three called stassi gets called
out for the third time tonight
[Applause]
that's a great swing
that's two really good swings in a row
going the other way but that one right
there that is a line drive the other way
that's a hard hit ball right into the
glove of elvis sanders knocked him over
that one's hit well
right center field marte on the move
marte in front of the wall tracks it
down fires it back in ohtani hustling
back and he's gonna be safe
first and third now two down bottom of
the night denny jose rojas will be the
next batter
well we mentioned stassi's had a rough
night tonight three strikeouts he could
have a good night though if he comes
through here
a little flare and it's caught by
harrison on a snow cone to end the game
a game of inches and it went the a's way